covered
is
spreading so rapidly if you notice
it just it just happened almost
overnight just in the last month and so
no
it's not a failure
but the alarm bell went off i don't
think anybody
anticipated that this was going to be as
rapidly spreading as it did
that's not going to age well for joe
biden the president claims a new variant
came out of nowhere even though the
white house warned everybody about it
weeks ago and now his own cdc director
says he's full of it watch we
anticipated this this is what we have
been preparing for there have been
doubling times of this virus in other
countries that have had the virus before
us in the one and a half to three day
range and so this is exactly what we
anticipated biden also being called out
for the long wait lines just to get a
test
and a shortage of at-home ones but let's
not play into biden's doom and gloom
winner of death message there's some
very good news on the coveted front the
new study says omicron has an 80 percent
lower risk of hospitalization
and even though biden doesn't want to
talk about this the fda just authorized
a potential game-changing anti-viral
pill to treat kovitt that greatly
decreases hospitalizations and death it
could become available in the next
coming weeks
so i think we all have to acknowledge
here we're in boxes we don't want to be
in boxes we hate being in boxes we
resisted being in boxes we were told to
be in a box
out of abundance of caution just to get
us through the holidays and hopefully
we'll be back to normal table situation
when we return from said holiday greg
gutfeld it's great to see you
your thoughts on the covid developments
yes i find it heartbreaking that i can't
be close to harold
that work
this this
love and the time of pandemic is
destroying us
there he is so far away yet i can see
him i can almost touch him
but i won't you know what's amazing how
far ahead
this show has been on a lot of things
for example we were the first show i
think to talk about the travel ban and
to talk about telemedicine and yet there
seems to be all these epiphanies
happening on other networks and fouchy's
saying you know what we should focus on
the severity and not the number of cases
and cnn's like wow that's a great idea
it's like no we have been saying this
forever and that's what's that's why we
what we said about omicron is that
you're going to see a lot of cases but
not a lot of severity and so the cases
are mild and then that leads you to the
next thing
what is the government and what is fauci
doing with this 10-day isolation thing
if everybody is being tested and getting
omicron why are these forced to sit home
for 10 days they got we know what the
right thing to do is and that is today
to cut that down to three or four days
and let people get back to work
especially my staff on gutfeld who are
sitting at home watching me right now
omicron is the next to the last scene in
a movie after the climax where the
townspeople thank the hero the villain
is seemingly defeated but then in that
last scene the villain rises up
and then he's easily vanquished this is
this
pandemic movie is about over the
estimated running time it's going to end
on february 1st a lot of us are going to
have omicron we're going to be fine we
just have to work together and also be
patient with our befuddled government
one last movie analogy remember with
rocky it was apollo creed versus rocky
but then the next sequels they were
working together they became partners
that's kind of what we have to be with
the government now they need our help
they're like a blind man
in an unfamiliar room
and we're in that room and we've got to
offer them guidance and help to get to
the right decisions we actually now have
to take the lead and announce that this
ends on february 1st
all right uh and you really think your
staff is at home watching you right now
greg
they they they adore me unlike your
staff who just hate you with a passion
my staff's definitely not watching me
right now uh harold ford jr do you
reciprocate greg gutfeld's longing
for you
a lot of love
between us on this show i'm glad to be
back around the proverbial table
and uh absolutely i i i would say this
uh jesse about the about the about the
the substance at hand uh you know i
think we are kind of in a got you moment
all the time around around this thing i
mean anytime we can have a politician
that that says something that we may
disagree with or make may differ with
something or subsequently be
contrary to something he or she may said
we jump on him a little bit i think the
science is changing and i think where
greg is most pointed where he's most
right is that it's going to take people
it's going to take business leaders it's
going to take everyday workers everyday
families to be the one to lead us
through all of this
and if we are if we get through this
variant here i think we will find
ourselves because of what scientists and
doctors are saying that this thing is so
transmissible and that hurt immunity
could rise so quickly but that should
not dissuade anyone from getting the
vaccine those who are eligible for
getting a booster
getting the booster because i think
we we don't know fully what's what's in
front of us over the next several months
i hope and believe and pray this is what
this is the last stages of it but if
it's not one thing is for certain our
best weapon against the virus against
those who may have wanted this virus to
get to us and our best way to be able to
compete and keep schools open and our
economy open
is to get vaccinated well i for one
enjoy jumping on politicians harold
because they work for us and katie i
think it's worth pointing out this is
the second time
that this has happened earlier this week
kamala harris said oh you know none of
the scientists told us this was going to
spread and come so quickly fauci had to
come back and say what he said and now
the cdc director had to tell the
president no no no no we warned you we
did see this coming
what's going on over there in your
opinion
well i think the biden administration is
getting eaten alive by the bureaucracy
because the left believes in big
government bureaucracy and they believe
in putting everything in one basket so
for over the past year the bite
administration has been focused on
vaccination which is fine but they've
been not focusing enough on treatments
and getting tests out to people and now
you're seeing the results of that as the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated continue
to get this disease and when it comes to
what greg is saying and giving the
politicians and the government a little
bit of
grace maybe in patience i think a lot of
people are over that and there comes a
point where you have to say no you have
to say no i'm not going to show my
papers to get into a restaurant no i'm
not going to do x y and z you saw the
election in virginia it was actually not
just about the economy in virginia for
the governorship it was about getting
rid of a lot of these obsessive coveted
regulations when the majority of the
country has moved on the white house
panicked about omicron and then they
turn right around and said that we we
don't know you know anthony fauci said
that you all need to go out and get a
test before christmas which then flooded
the testing sites with healthy people
who don't have symptoms so people who
have symptoms could no longer get a test
they created the crisis that they're in
now and they have no plans to get out of
it other than mandating americans do
even more than they've already done so
far wrap it up dana
okay so i think that everyone has been
way too easy on the biden administration
here and i am glad that i'm going to
bring the hammer down because they said
they were going to follow the science
they literally said they're going to
fall asleep they said they're going to
crush the virus
and we if you and i all know
that the south african said on november
8th that we have a new variant and we
knew christmas was also always on
december 25th
how could they possibly say that they
didn't know and that there weren't a
million reporters today saying you
better own up to this it's just surpri
it surprises me if it happened to a
republican administration that would
have been the only thing we talked about
today they've got some big problems
there and i don't think they're going to
get solved they're going to be saved by
the february 1st bell though
because i do think that we'll actually
see people
they'll get a lot a lot of people are
going to get this i'm sorry for the
people that are going to have a lot of
discomfort or maybe even hospitalized
but the data coming from south africa
and the uk shows that it probably will
not be that way what's really causing
the problems is that what greg mentioned
which is the cdc protocol that if you
test positive you automatically have to
quarantine for 10 days
that means that nobody can do anything
you can't go to work and can't go to
shopping you can't do anything so we all
have to figure out a way to pressure the
cdc to really look at that today the uk
went from ten to seven the last thing i
would say is
they own everything that is wrong with
the testing and it touches everybody if
you have people standing in line in 30
degree weather for four hours and that
leads the news as it did last night on
network news and it was in the daily
this morning it led npr like this is
permeated all across the country so
you'll see those approval numbers on
coronavirus go down wow when dana
perrino's dropping the hammer
harder than gunfell than katie
watch out white house you guys better
get it together
all right coming up the squad smears
against joe manchin going to a whole new
level